[Musique]
soit à tous bienvenue dans point de vue
un message d'abord à tous les fans de
marie amélie lombard soyez rassurés elle
sera de retour mardi prochain
mais dès jeudi donc vous restez avec
nous d'ailleurs jérôme sainte-marie est
avec nous c'est le retour sur figaro
live et ça mérite d'être saluée en tant
que tel on est ravi de vous avoir
on rappelle que vous êtes le président
de la société d'études et de conseil
pôle inbox
alors on sait que vous êtes l'auteur du
nouvel ordre démocratique 2015 et d'un
fauteuil pour 10 en 2006
ce qu'on sait moins c'est que vous avez
contribué à la mise en place d' enquêtes
d'opinion en afghanistan et que vous
êtes un as des sondages dans les
manifestations et d'ailleurs on va
reparler dans un instant avec nous
également béatrice giblin bon choix donc
sa directrice de l'indispensable revue
hérodote est responsable de l'institut
français de géopolitique et spécialiste
de la france de demain c'est le dossier
d'ailleurs de la dernière livraison de
votre revue avec vous avec à vos côtés
philippe teurs la voie la plus british
de la radio française de la radio du
monde puisque c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle radio france internationale et
alexis brézet directeur des rédactions
du groupe figaro et elle s'occupe depuis
alexis alors la question ce soir bien ce
sont des questions et c'est des
questions de journalistes quand comment
qui ou et accessoirement pourquoi quand
sera remanié le nouveau gouvernement
comment où et cela sera t-il annoncé
surtout qu'ils qui sera promu qui sera
convié qui sera chassé
réponse peut-être au cours de cette
émission est voulu vivre en direct ou
réponse après et là aussi vous pourrez
vivre en direct ce sera sur figure le
figaro et ce sera en live
en attendant on vous donne une info les
syndicats ont été mobilisés
aujourd'hui c'était une journée d'action
question le saviez vous et bien dites
nous si oui si vous dites nous si non et
on essaiera de savoir pourquoi au
l'autre question c'est entre mauriac et
garcia marquez ou chardonne caché
feriez-vous dans la bibliothèque d'un
homme d'état de françois mitterrand est
ce que question subsidiaire la
connaissance de la littérature est
nécessaire à l'exercice du pouvoir
vous avez moins d'une heure pour
répondre à la question ou plutôt pour
faire plancher
nos invités alors emmanuel macron depuis
à son agenda
ce soir doit s'exprimer devant la
station f
et pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
nouveau gouvernement
est-ce qu'on a une question à votre avis
qu'est ce qui se passe ça risque de tout
bon la vérité c'est d'abord je pense que
nous autres journées sont suspendus à
cette affaire un peu par fonction
commentateurs aussi assemble de
responsables politiques sont suspendus à
cette affaire après je pense pas qu'ils
n'en voient absolument phénoménale et
règne au pays en se demandant alors
est-ce qu'on a un remaniement pas de
remaniement bon une fois qu'on a dit ça
c'est un peu notre métier de regarder et
c'est vrai que ça fait huit jours qu'on
attend et huit jours que ça coince c'est
un fait pourquoi parce que c'est un rom
c'est d'abord un remaniement c'est
toujours compliqué celui là l'est je
pense doublement d'abord parce que
d'abord c'est un remaniement qui sert au
maniement subi c'est pas un choix ce
maquereau n'a pas décidé de changer
maintenant il a vu un ministre partir un
important ministre est donc maintenant
il faut qu'il trouve il faudra passer
donc le rapt la sage c'est plus
compliqué est deuxième et enfin dernier
point de complexité c'est l'intérieur
l'intérieur c'est pas un ministère comme
les autres c'est un ministère qui exige
de plein de qualités différentes
prémices de l'intérieur c'est les
questions de terrorisme et de sécurité
évidemment c'est aussi des questions
électorales c'est l'homme qui va faire
le redécoupage électoral
c'est quelqu'un qui s'occupe de plein de
choses de renseignement et qui aura
plein de secrets entre les mains donc il
faut qu'il est absolument la confiance
absolue du président et du premier
ministre
donc tout ça fait que cette affaire
n'est pas simple et donc ça traîne
voilà donc ce n'est pas un drame mais si
on veut essayer de comprendre les choses
faut le dire simplement ça ça coince
al'inverse de ce que disait
olivier duhamel la semaine dernière
olivier nous disais ici même qu'avec la
démission suivie de colomb macron s'est
fait piéger par son obsession de
maîtriser des horloges en faisant durer
le plaisir il reprend pas un peu la main
non c'est en refusant ge dans mon
souvenir la tristesse de liste et comme
disait c'est à dire que refusant de
laisser partir collomb quand il
demandait à partir quitter le bon sens
même il sait coin il s'est piégé sort
était plus simple de dire quand que l'on
a dit finalement ben je songe à autre
chose ça veut dire merci tu t'en vas
cela dit ça n'aurait pas simplifier le
le choix du remplaçant de colomb et je
pense que si macron précisément ne veut
pas laisser partir que l'on ça n'est pas
uniquement pour dire c'est moi le chef
et c'est moi qui décide c'est aussi
qu'il ne sait pas par qui le remplacer
la preuve il ne sait pas par qui le
remplacer on en revient toujours à la
même question c'est quand même très
simple avis on a quelqu'un qui s'en va
il faut trouver quelqu'un pour le
remplacer
et si on ne trouve pas c'est plus long
que prévu et ce qui est pourtant simple
d'habitude afin avant macron c'est qu'on
arrive quand même à dans ces cas-là
remaniait c'est assez rapidement je
remet simplement oui sauf que souvent
les remaniements et yquem prévu à
l'avance comme l'a dit alexis brézet
l'instant c'est un remaniement
particulièrement subi qui suit à un
remaniement raté enfin le maniement mort
nez si j'ose dire c'est à dire le
remaniement qui aurait pu avoir lieu
après le départ de nicolas hulot aurait
été assez logique
il y avait une attente là on voyait des
calmes à quelques ministres on se disait
qu'ils étaient remplaçable pour le mois
et là il y avait on était à la rentrée
après un été difficile on pourrait
penser que rsa banon après la crise au
de crédibilité personnelle qu'a subies
le prétend la république durant l'été et
dont nicolas hulot a été un nouvel
épisode
et bien non il a préféré temporiser
faire une promotion interne et
cannibalisé en quelque sorte la
république en marche pour remplacer
nicolas hulot est hélas ils se
retrouvent dans une crise tout à fait
importante alors pourquoi est ce que
c'est important peut-être moins pour
l'opinion française en général
et là c'est le sondeur qui parle qu'on
est désolé a livré ce lundi c'est pas on
n'est pas sous la ive république en plus
on part on pense pas non plus que ce
remaniement correspondre à un tournant
de la politique économique ou autre
donc c'est pas un événement politique de
première ampleur pour les français la
hausse est plus embêtant c'est en train
de se passer
tant pis dans cette ambiance comment
dirais-je d'improvisation de l'embarras
qui semble se dégager peut-être contre
noah une surprise incroyable tout sera
tous mes propos seront annulés enfin
pour l'instant nos jours alors on parle
c'est comme cela que l'on ressent c'est
gênant non pas pour l'opinion en général
mais c'est gênant pour les cadres la
politique pour les élus la réplique en
marche à un énorme problème c'est pas
les élections européennes enfin pas
seulement
c'est surtout les prochaines élections
municipales et là il ya c'est le
praticien qui parle un tout petit peu
les gens je voyais en juin dans les
communes de france demandaient les élus
se demandait comment avoir l'investiture
de la république en marche pour 2020 en
septembre il se pose une toute autre
question sait pas comment l'éviter faut
pas exagérer mais en tout cas c'est un
peu la question que j'ai emporté duquel
tout cela voilà des mois je m'en vais et
surtout se prendrait pas pour lyon la
masse est sûre en mars
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
signe annoncé à camoufler d'ailleurs
c'est ce que dit ce que dit le dernier
sondage aux docks ça mais béatrice
giblin votre analyse
il est plus facile de remplacer un
général cinq étoiles que de remplacer un
ministre l'intérieur
incontestablement ça c'est d'évidence
beaucoup plus simple aulas un général
enfin ça dépend si on veut qu'il soit
très bon c'est peut-être un peu
difficile on peut pas forcément savoir
mais on revient ce jeu revient sur la
démission du dos là aussi on est quand
même dans quelque chose qui est subi
l'eau aux annoncé à france inter un
matin qu'il n'a même pas prévenu le
président de la république le premier
ministre et qui le mec comme ça sur la
table
c'était aussi très très inédit que cette
affaire l'a donc même un remaniement
juste après cette démission public
du lot même si on pouvait se dire et
finira par en avoir assez les couleuvres
il va cesser de vouloir les avaler
néanmoins ça aurait été sous une
décision qu'il n'avait pas prise et
c'est là où effectivement on peut
s'interroger parce que il se dit que le
premier ministre edouard philippe
souhaité un remaniement déjà depuis
quelques temps c'est à dire qu'il
préférait un remaniement à froid après
un été effectivement qui a été pour le
moins perturbée et de repartir avec une
équipe avant même de faire cette rentrée
il n'a pas été entendu et maintenant
dans la volonté de d'emmanuel macron de
refuser la démission dans un premier
temps de colomb je pense qu'il n'a pas
pensé que l'on n'était pas un homme
d'état il a surestimé le personnage il
s'est dit il ne peut pas faire ça on va
avoir des échéances extrêmement
importante
il ya même un g6 des ministres à
l'intérieur à lyon en ce moment il a il
a ne s'attendait pas à l'analyse que je
fais est qu à ce qu'il put s qu'il
puisse manquer à ce point à sa parole et
à ses responsables et à ses
responsabilités c'est plein de la
naïveté de la part du du président de la
république il a surestimé sa capacité
d'influencé d'autorité sur kolo du corps
vient le voir le temps je veux partir il
lui dit non tu pars pas à peine un an et
l'autre dit bon bon d'accord il a
magnifiquement je me suis levé et je
vais dire au figaro que je pars je pense
que c'est ça on peut faire cette analyse
là vous leur posez sur un acte
exclusivement d'autorité voilà ce te dit
non tu pars pas on ne sait pas le
contenu de cette de ce qui s'est dit
vraiment vous avez peut-être d entrée
que je n'ai pas mais ça a pu être le cas
il a annoncé au figaro qui démissionnait
pas séparer de démissionner soir vous
avez
suivi d'un et même prévenu le premier
ministre
en plaine en pleine assemblée nationale
donc vous étiez effectivement aux
premières loges
voilà mes bons pour en revenir à ça moi
ce que je trouve tout à fait étonnant
c'est comment quelqu'un comme comme
colons en ce moment aussi important pour
bon pour le pays dans ce rôle qui l'a de
ministre de l'intérieur
oser faire des sorties comme il les a
faites en partant c'est quand même
invraisemblable
enfin si le problème ça c'est le
problème de la justement de l'autorité
qu'il a défié de l'autorité défier du
président mais pour venir à s'en excuser
moi mais au delà de l'autorité défier du
président il était en charge en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur en particulier
sur les banlieues dont le plan de borloo
a été traité mais énormément mis à la
poubelle en deux temps trois mouvements
sans ça va bien les plans banlieues
alors qu'on sait très bien qu'il ya un
problème de fond et qu'on n'a pas mis
tant d'argent de ça dans les banlieues
depuis depuis aussi aussi longtemps que
ça et qu'il ose dire l'heure est grave
il faut vraiment s'occuper des banlieues
la république n'est plus maître dans
certains quartiers bas oui qu'est ce que
tu as fais toi depuis 18 mois ce n'est
pas ton boulot ça ça c'est quand même
invraisemblable de dire une chose comme
ça c'est moi qui ai été pour ma part en
tant que citoyenne parfaitement choqué
philippe torres que cette ce choc et ce
scandale ressentie par béatrice giblin
il est ressenti à l'étranger également
en ce qui concerne le remaniement
aujourd'hui absolument pas je veux dire
que pour moi alors il ya deux choses je
vis en france je vis la vie politique
française comme vous tous les jours et
bon gré mal gré je sais que c'est pas
facile pour macron je viendrai se
comprendre lui depuis la grande bretagne
dans un instant mais il ya des choses
qu'on sait déjà on sait que probablement
ça va être un grand remaniement ça pas
être te prendre deux ou trois personnes
les mettent à la page de trois personnes
parce que ça traîne donc pour mâcon ça
serait plus
propice de faim dissaux dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale
renommé depuis le perron élyséen nouveau
un nouveau gouvernement doit faire la
photo et c'est à eux de faire un
discours politique générale c'est un peu
tôt en gros pour lui de le faire parce
qu'il voit il fallait pas tourner à pas
les élections de l'année prochaine sont
eux les élections européennes avant de
faire le gouvernement
macron 2 mais il a eu la main font c'est
justement par gérard colomb que je
trouve rancunier après l affaire benalla
gates je pense que c'était la goutte qui
a fait déborder la vase et je pense que
colom a senti trahi prend macron parce
que il a pris un bain à la com' gare de
coursan lui en parler je pense que c'est
là où ça commence à vraiment cas contre
les hommes lisent mais juste pour mener
sur la l'image de maquereaux à
l'étranger je vais être un peu dur avec
vous parce que je pense que vous rendez
par contre la perte de la personne que
vous avez en france qui est toujours
très bien vu depuis l'étranger même si
il est moins bien vu ici parce que c'est
le seul vraiment en europe qui peut
contrer trempe qui peut contrer poutine
qui peut proposer le renforcement de
l'union européenne face à merkel qui est
quand même très affaiblie la grande
bretagne et qui aideront en plein bourg
excite malheureusement donc bon il faut
pas trop le le le
le mettre à la poubelle aussi macron
bosquet il sait a quand même à quelque
chose même vu de l'étranger par par nul
et les journalistes étrangers à paris
journalistes étrangers à paris la nuance
est important c'est le cas c'est le vase
qui a qui a déjà débordé mais il y a on
fait parfois des sondages à l'étranger
pour se voir l'image des présidents etc
comment dirais-je je m'étais convaincu
qu'il était bon pour un peuple que son
président soit parfaitement populaire
dans les autres pays c'est souvent à ce
même parfois un indicateur trompeur
voire contre-productif
je prends ces problèmes qui affectent
donald trump en france vous avez
l'exemple de salvini par exemple salvini
et très populaire en italie
il a une image
un mauvais jour d'autre part tous les
pays européens mais dans d'autres pays
comme le nôtre je suis pas sûr que ce
soit un indicateur si vous voulez très
très décisif
le fait que lino que celle avec le
président le ministre italien et une
mauvaise image en france que ce soit les
indicateurs que sa politique soit
particulièrement mauvaise pour revenir
sur votre sur ce point qu'un seul aspect
c'est un homme qui sait parler à tracter
par la poutine l'a justement on touche
un des problèmes de la période pour le
pouvoir français pour emmanuel macron il
avait effectivement installés durant son
élection et puis après son élection
7 comment dirais-je on avait
l'impression d'un pouvoir quasiment
magique
si vous voulez d'un charisme
extraordinaire et que grâce à sa
personne il allait pouvoir résoudre tous
les problèmes qui ne lui avait pas été
auparavant et qu'il pouvait justement
convaincre par son magnétisme personnel
monsieur train à monsieur poutine etc et
qui pouvaient résoudre aussi des
problèmes de du vieux monde
eh bien on se rend compte au cours des
derniers mois que d'une part cette
séduction supposé pour monsieur trump et
bien nous donne pas de résultats
tangibles à ma connaissance par monsieur
poutine non plus on renvoie pas et qu'au
niveau français en tout cas et c'est de
désaveu qui lavent les deux camouflets
qu'il a subie avec le ministre
l'écologie le ministre de l'intérieur
sont la preuve que cette magie justement
ne perd plus de charisme
à mon avis a disparu dans la tête des
gens on prend les questions des
internautes jaune qui dit pourquoi ce
remaniement est il si non à venir et
bien on l'a expliqué au début de cette
émission jeunes c'est parce que
notamment le remaniement est un
remaniement subi et j'aimerais que on
touche du doigt laquelle une des
faiblesses
objectif de cette année et demie de
vacances c'est l'incapacité dans
laquelle il a été par uniquement de sa
faute à mettre en place une relève dire
que son grand pas restée calme je vais
renouveler
la pratique politique et renouveler les
hommes ben finalement un an et demi il
n'y a pas d'homme nouveau qui soit
apparu il n'y a pas de nouveaux qui sont
parus et les anciens s'en vont parce que
nos 120 bayrou est partie que l'on sait
donc si les vieux parts et que de
nouveaux n'apparaissent pas il se
retourne et on cherche on cherche on
trouve pas et ça c'est quand même pour
l'avenir c'est comme chose de
préoccupant c'est que si mac on n'arrive
pas à structurer un dispositif partisans
avec des individus autour de lui comment
il va faire pour la suite
les européennes ya les municipales fait
une vie politique ne peut pas retenir un
qu'on peut gagner une élection
présidentielle sur un homme mais ensuite
et c'est peut-être ça le une des erreurs
de macron c'est de croire qu'on peut
structurer une conquête et une pratique
politique et une perpétuation politique
sur un homme mais à un moment il faut
s'entourer et là ça marche et c'est ce
que dit de vicky et ça c'est le le défi
qu'il a parce que justement c'est ce que
dira les internautes c'est parce qu'il
n'a pas le même vivier que les ps et l
air d'antan
concernant le remaniement babineau lui
dise c'est un remaniement de façade il
essaye d'apporter un vent de fraîcheur
mais ces règles qui fait non pro actif
il faut un électrochoc pour le fait pour
faire basculer l'opinion publique
un remaniement est clairement
insuffisant dit babineau qu'il y ait un
vrai remaniement serait de remplacer le
premier ministre qui est absolument
inexistant alors justement le premier
ministre et bien il est un peu sous
pression en tous les cas sous la
pression des questions des journalistes
depuis ces dernières heures et il s'est
notamment exprimé hier soir on l'écouté
écoutez le ministre de l'intérieur au
moment où nous vous parlons c'est bon
alors il sert et exprimer cet après midi
il était redevenu premier ministre et il
était interpellé par le président du
groupe
lr à l'assemblée on écoute les changes
entre christian jacob et dort film vous
êtes aujourd'hui incapable de proposer
un gouvernement crédible à la france
tancé le vide autour de vous jusque
quand cette mascarade va-t-elle
continuer monsieur le premier ministre
dans votre question j'ai entendu quelque
chose qui m'apparaît relever d'une forme
de fébrilité et d'impatience mais je
vais vous dire une chose monsieur jacob
nous ne transigerons en rien sur les
engagements qui ont été pris par le
président de la république nous mettrons
en oeuvre la politique que nous avons
affiché et sur laquelle nous nous sommes
engagés aux élections présidentielle et
aux élections législatives aux jambes
sainte-marie edouard philippe il est
renforcée après cet échange dont il est
inexistant comme guillaume notre
internaute
moi je trouve je trouvais l'internaute
extrêmement sévère edouard philippe et
déjà alors s'est désolé de faire des
sondages mais plus populaire que le
présent de la république il est à 6 soit
37 % derrière dans le dernier sondage
hawks à tous les deux 32 et 39 enfin bon
on verra mais en tout cas il a et ces
derniers mois les a quand même plutôt
été davantage populaire ce qui est
d'ailleurs une tradition maintenant sous
le quinquennat les premiers ministres
seront davantage populaires parfois
considérablement que le président de la
république ce ne sont plus des boucliers
au contraire mais longtemps ça va
profiter attirer la lumière vers je
trouve qu edouard philippe et c'est
plutôt comment dirais-je a été plutôt
renforcé par les péripéties on va dire
de l'été qui ont affecté l'image du
président de la république image
personnelle mais qui ont fait que
finalement que lui il incarne il incarne
l'état il faut le dire de manière assez
assez convaincante et sa discrétion
n'est pas forcément un handicap joueurs
là dessus je veux par rapport à beaucoup
de commentaires que j'entends le but
n'est pas forcément s'il voulait d'être
omniprésent et là il est il se montre à
la fois loyal discret
il a tenu la maison s'ils voulaient
quand on voyait le président de la
république
mobilisés par des affaires à ses
subalternes lance effectivement
qu'edouard philippe avec le calme qui
donne dont il donne l'impression
systématiquement tout le temps sa façon
de prendre la parole sans mauvais jeu de
mots sa hauteur de vue le fait qu'ils
dominent toujours toutes les assemblées
beaucoup c'est que il
je pense qu'au contraire ils gagnent en
épaisseur et en consistance dans ces
moments de un peu instable un peu floués
et c'est presque un problème pour macron
qui apparaît comme étant plus plus
incertain plus est plus dans le doute
sipa dans le doute en tout cas maladroit
c'est la question je souhaite aux as aux
internautes est-ce que selon vous
emmanuel macron reprend lama et ils font
face avec ce que vous dites qu'on n'a
pas de remaniement peut pas dire que
pour le moment ils reprennent la main
donc on sait pas qui va m comment il va
s'y prendre et quelle ampleur ça va
avoir c'est bien qu'on va en avoir
quelques uns qui vont sortir ça
m'étonnerait que madame nissan reste par
exemple
bon tout en terme d'opinion qu'elle
remaniement a fait reprendre la main
aucun
donc la question est réglée c'est pas un
remaniement qui permet de reprendre la
main à un remaniement quand il ya un
changement premier ministre changement
va pas changer
beaucoup ne peut pas compter et ministre
parce qu'il trouve même pas misé
l'intérieur donc il va pas mettre un
nouveau premier ministre et donc la
question est est ce que ce remaniement
va renforcer et doit flip
je pense que oui je pense qu'il va
recenser gagnons ce soir maniement parce
qu'il va être nommé il va avoir un
nouveau gouvernement donc nécessairement
ça ira bien pour lui et la deuxième
question est ce que ça va remettre la
politique des maillots m'a consolé rails
et roy booster ces sondages
là je suis beaucoup plus prudent et j'ai
du mal à croire que ça changera grand
chose dans les médias s'agissant de
philippe autant je considère que c'est à
l'internaute est très sévère ya aucune
raison de dire qu'il est nul qui sert à
rien tu iras il fait plutôt bien le job
il est sérieux et c'est pour autant moi
je m'inscris pas dans cette façon de
voir kim on avait très parisienne et
très journalistique de dire ah la la
edouard philippe est en train de de
gêner mieux le maquereau de prendre la
place nous non il fait le job
il fait son boulot mais comment dire il
n'y a pas de il est nerveux - pourquoi
macron aujourd'hui baisse cédant son
action qui fait qu'ils baissent c'est
qu'il est nerveux les jambes a plein de
fautes de comportement edouard philippe
ne fait comme est passé faute de ce
point de vue il est nerveux - même temps
y'a pas de lien de droit philippe à
l'opinion y'a pas d'incarnation de venir
à philippe dans l'opinion
il n'y a pas de magnétisme de voir filer
visite opinion il est là il fait bien le
job mais je crois pas qu'ils aient
aujourd'hui n'a pas construit quelque
chose de fort les questions sur les
doors fit d'ailleurs on a on annonçait
la position du premier okami dans la
vème république
non mais justement il est juste bien
blanc doit être parent dont je vous
coupe il ya une chose dont on attend
qu'on attendait qu'on annonçait depuis
ces dernières heures c'est qu'il devait
présenter sa démission au président et
comment vous interprétez le crime qui
n'est pas absurde
d'abord qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
d'abord on a considéré va la présenter
le soir
et vas y vas être nommé le lendemain on
ne peut pas il faut d'ailleurs de
vacances de l'état imaginez qu il la
moindre événement il faut quand même que
des ministres
pour donner des ordres aux la police il
faut enfin on termine juridique on peut
pas organiser la vacance de l'état donc
déjà de dire qu'ils démissionnent le
soir pour revenir lentement et à cette
action et deuxièmement l'idée de
démissionner pour être renommé ça veut
dire qu'il va y aura un vote de
confiance un nouveau vote de confiance à
l'assemblée
est-ce que c'est l'intérêt aujourd'hui
de 2,2 de voir philippe retenter le
redemander un vote de confiance à
l'assemblée
je pense que par rapport au présent il
ne peut que perdre mathématiquement il a
fait le plein dernière fois il peut pas
avoir plus en revanche il aura toujours
quelques centristes qui sont énervés qui
voudront pu voter pour lui
quelque chose de vraiment goode qui
était entre le ps et les marcheurs qui
diront oh non on n'est pas content donc
moi je vois pas bien l'intérêt d'aller
se refaire taper dessus à l'assemblée
pour à l'arrivée avoir moins de avoir
moins de deux jours je crois que
légalement ils voir philippe à un autre
problème
je te leur jeu répondu sur le jugement
sur l'homme et la manière dont on vit là
il assume ses fonctions de premier
ministre me paraît tout à fait correct
la houle a un problème plus politique
c'est que justement c'était une prise de
guerre mais une remarquable la formation
du gouvernement d'edouard philippe a été
décisif pour décider pour les élections
législatives qui ont suivi et il a
permis aussi avec bruno le maire et
d'autres de drainer vers dans le soutien
à l'exécutif de drainer de très nombreux
sympathisants de droite au point
d'ailleurs que emmanuel macron ça paraît
loin désormais en janvier et est devenue
majoritairement populaire 50 52 %
c'était assez rare vous voyez quelqu'un
qui baisse qui remonte comme ça à
présent la république nicolas sarkozy
l'avait fait mais c'est assez rare et
c'était grâce justement aux soutiens de
beaucoup de sympathisants de droite
notamment dans un contexte de mouvement
sociaux et là ce qui s'est passé durant
depuis janvier et qui s'est terriblement
accéléré ces derniers mois
c'est a été le retour le retour des
sympathisants de droite vers notamment
le party les républicains
oui donc si vous voulez vous avez hélas
edouard philippe il sert à ça aussi
notamment la perspective des prochaines
échéances électorales
et ça pour l'instant ça ne marche plus
il est il est en train quand même de
profiter du fait que ça va pas très bien
entre la france assume et le parti
communiste on se marie le pen et dupont
aignan donc l'opposition n'est pas
vraiment là pour qu'on ferait donc il a
quand même dit on par rapport à sarkozy
ou au lond
l'opposition est quand même très divisée
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle oui
ce que dit jérôme sainte marie c'est
qu'apparemment à droite il ya un nouveau
soutien qui revient dans l'opinion et
que pour l'instant wauquiez a évoqué
qu'à ceux d'alice pas ça non feint
d'être très net que dans la soirée
soutien au gouvernement soutient au
pouvoir et au président de la république
les beaucoup de sympathisants de droite
qui étaient venus sont aujourd'hui
reparti et donc vous l'avez vous tombez
à 25-30 % de bonnes opinions pour le
présent de la république
à droite c'est un peu plus quelle gauche
va couper que ce qui reste de la gauche
enfin et ça c'est très important
notamment parce que y'a plein de
catégories sociales qui votent davantage
pour la droite que les autres qui ont
été très déçus évidemment retraités et
juste pour finir
et effectivement on dit y'a pas de
problème et si on est en crise politique
majeure enfin majeur crise politique ça
n'aboutira pas à une révolution mais
c'est bien tout simplement parce qu'il
ya absence de résultats attentes
fondamentales français le chômage serait
en train de baisser tout c'est qu'elles
sont là ne serait plus je me suis même
pas sûr
regardez jospin je sais pas il ya des
bons résultats économiques le chômage
baisse la croissance revient tout va
bien il est même pas compte officiel
très populaire c'est beaucoup plus qu il
est même pas au second tour ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué le soutien des
électeurs de droite comme il pouvait la
voir mais ses électeurs de droite pour
l'instant ne se sont pas arrangées non
plus n'ont donc ils sont encore dans une
position attentiste d'une certaine façon
qui peut aussi bouger et quand on voit
simplement vos questions prend le
baromètre des personnalités comme on l'a
vu
alors ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
et c'est plein de contradictions
il est quand même parmi les derniers
le show qu'on souhaite voir exercer des
responsabilités
c'est quand même
un peu un peu gênante on va continuer à
suivre ça dans les prochaines heures si
il y à une annonce d'une façon ou d'une
autre et bien bien sûr on l'a on la
retransmettra si elle est faite sur le
perron de l'elysée notamment où on vous
la donnera dans le courant de cette
émission je laisse le dernier mot aux
internautes un vrai ça tu repars donc il
nous dit l'arrêt à propos de vous
philippe turn a raison de dire que macro
et bienvenue à l'étranger non seulement
c'est vrai mais surtout le seul depuis
très longtemps
macabre ditto nous dit de voir philippe
n'a pas caché son intention possible de
retourner la politique locale ça n'est
jamais bon signe
et il ajoute edouard philippe est à mon
avis dans la lignée des premiers
ministres services du président il y à
une autre question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui elle est un peu brutal c'est
les syndicats sert-il à quelque chose
je ne sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais c'était l'évènement du jour du
moins quand on regarde l agenda afp y
encore quelques jours ou quelques heures
c'est la mobilisation dans les rues
alors avant de voir combien de personnes
ont été mobilisées je vous propose quand
même d'écouter les responsables
syndicaux qui expliquait pourquoi ils
avaient appelé leurs adhérents à
manifester aujourd'hui on est dans la
rue contre une vision qui est porté par
le chef de l'état et son gouvernement
qui est une logique d'individualisation
de casse de notre modèle social et c'est
le modèle social finalement que nous
défendons c'est à dire notamment les
cadres collectifs les statuts les
conventions collectives mais aussi la
sécurité sociale et les retraites
alors ça c'est la version pavageau le
nouveau patron de force ouvrière et il
ya la version martin f
c'est le problème de monsieur macron il
a du mal à se mettre à la place de ceux
qui travaillent en tout cas il connaît
pas le monde du travail
vous imaginez moi je vais dans les
hôpitaux par exemple des infirmes me
disent mais tu te rends compte à 63 ans
à 64 ans est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'occuper de façon sérieuse des patients
les manipulent etc
c'est ça la réalité il faut il faut
sortir des schémas des théories fumeuses
alors 2500 à cinquante mille personnes
ont manifesté à pareille en tout cas
selon les chiffres qui sont donnés par
la fp à l'instant si vous n'avez
a été marqué par cet événement
rassurez-vous le patron de la cgt nous a
donné un élément en tout cas un indice
dans les colonnes du figaro justement
ces dernières heures philippe martinez
le reconnaît il faut réinventer de
nouvelles formes de luttes pour les
syndicats une question simple les
syndicats ont-ils encore une utilité de
dribble bien sûr que les syndicats ont
encore une utilité
on peut que regretter qu'il y ait soit
aussi faible
c'est dire si on a plus d'intermédiaires
si il ne ne servent plus de contacts de
lieu de négociation
je vous ferai remarquer que la cfdt
n'avait pas appelé à la manifestation
aujourd'hui il ya laurent berger est
absolument convaincu du rôle du syndicat
dans la nécessité on nous dit que c'est
un syndicat réformiste
oui peut-être mais avant de dire non on
essaye de négocier on essaie de voir ce
qu'on peut faire
on essaye de voir comment on peut tirer
quelques avantages pour les gens qu'on
représente et dont on a la
responsabilité
l'attitude de la cgt absolument
stupéfiante
quand même martinez qui dit un oui mais
le succès ça ne se compte pas au nombre
de manifestants s'est quand même
absolument
étonnant de sa part faut dire aussi que
depuis que maintenant on sait à peu près
très précisément combien il ya de
manifestants dans les rues grâce
d'ailleurs aux médias qui ont décidé de
se donner les moyens de les compter
sérieusement et que l'espoir ça m'allait
pas la paix nous avez vous n'allez pas
dépenser de l'argent pour ça et que
généralement c'est toujours les chiffres
correspond peu près toujours aux
chiffres de la police a joui après bon
donc il suffit maintenant d'avoir les
chiffres de la police pour savoir au
fond c'est 2500 bon 11500 et pas
cinquante mille voilà et moi j'ai pu me
rendre compte qu'il y avait des
manifestations parce que j'habite un
quartier où elle passait par là donc il
y avait un nombre de cars de crs qui m'a
fait dire ah oui c'est vrai il ya
manifestation aujourd'hui bon ce n'est
pas la vérité c'est chaud fois oui mais
bon pas grand chose georges qui j'en
suis persuadé
mais néanmoins les syndicats comptent
continue et devrait jouer un rôle tout à
fait important et c'est un risque si on
a des syndicats qui disparaît c'est qu'à
côté du débat certes intéressant mais un
peu théorique sur le rôle des syndicats
les syndicats se réduite ce serait utile
s'il était différent oui c'est sûr ce
qui me semble en tout cas pas tant c'est
que aujourd'hui les ce ne sont pas les
syndicats qui mettent en danger
macron c'est pas la contestation
syndicale c'est pas là au delà même des
conditions c'est même pas la
contestation de sa politique qui
affaiblit maintenant c'est intéressant
de voir que tous les trucs d'autoriser
ce sera dur c'est finalement très bien
passé désormais on ce travail et leurs
efforts de notre oeil s'est très bien
passé le la sncf c'est quand même pas
rien de dire qu'on allait finir et sept
du cheminot a eu des manifs mais tout ça
se passe assez bien et si ça se trouve
demain la question des retraites at on
dit c'est très difficile
ça passe on passera aussi peut-être pas
si mal parce que l'opinion évolue c'est
intéressant et un peu rageant d'un point
de vue démocratique de voir que ce qui
est en train de plomber macron c'est pas
son action c'est macron cesser les
petites phrases et sa façon d'être sa
façon de se comporter etc
mais la politique de macron en tout cas
en matière économique le régalien fait
encore autre chose c'est sans doute une
attente qui tu pars
kiki auquel rien ne répond mais sur
l'économie qui a pas de rejet massif de
la politique de macron sait plus
aujourd'hui sa pratique de sa politique
sait plus aujourd'hui ça l'homme à sa
façon de gouverner sa façon d'être le
sentiment qu'il donne la façon dont dix
considèrent les gens qui est en cause
que ce qu'il fait concrètement
moi j'aimerais tout à fait d'accord
parce que s'ils avaient rapidement des
résultats à sa politique sa façon dette
passerait beaucoup de monde donc ça ne
suffit pas à aller dire que le rejet
vient d'eux s'appelle en fait je vous
propose d'écouter un juge de paix sur ce
justement sur les politiques et les
répercussions de la politique dans le
pays veut tenir des propos qui sont pas
du tout contents super mais sur ce sujet
je crois qu'effectivement il ya le
prochain jeu précise pardon aux gens que
dans la question qu'on pose seins c'est
absolument personnage une question sur
twitter elle 77% encore des gens nous
disent qu'ils servent les syndicats ne
s'avale pourquoi pas mais c'est mon
engagement bonne année il n'a pas varié
si vous voulez depuis l'élection
emmanuel macron quant à la perspective
d'un blocage social je n'y ai jamais cru
pour des raison assez simple c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un rapport de force
donc d'être assez archaïque des analyses
je suis désolé très archaïque
il ya un rapport de force qui est
totalement en défaveur des salariés les
salaires il n'y a plus de syndicats dans
le secteur privé sauf des gens qui
veulent avoir des emplois protégés
généralement il n'y a plus de grèves
revendicatrice en france vous il faut le
dire quand même il ya des grèves lancées
dans le service public
il ya des grèves quand les us dans les
usines ou les établissements en tout cas
ferme et donc c'est pour négocier un
plan social plus avantageux généralement
mais il n'y a plus ces grandes grèves de
revendications donc de conquête qu'il y
avait autrefois tout simplement parce
que quand vous avez 6 millions de
chômeurs ou à peu près quand vous avez
beaucoup de précarité etc
il faut être d'un point de vue
individuel quel que soit votre sentiment
il faut vraiment être animés du sens du
martyr si vous voulez pour ce prêt pour
aller dans une entreprise privée
actuellement est annoncée des
revendications et c'est vous et prenez
là c'est l'option privilégiée pour
prendre la porte le premier pour avoir
les augmentations les promotions le
dernier donc il sait plus possible
aujourd'hui
et donc c'est pour simple le rapport de
forces est terriblement terriblement
défavorable d'autant plus que les
mouvements mobilisation sociale c'est
aussi des cycles et quand vous avez ça
fonctionne en spirale en quelque sorte
donc d'aller spirale négative et bien
peu à peu la mobilisation s'étiole c'est
ce que vous ça fait très longtemps qu'il
ne grève pas des grèves dans milieu
lycéen ou collégien qui font peur au
gouvernement par les risques de décès ou
de choses comme ça mais dans les mines
dans le niveau social
je pense qu'il ya quasiment depuis 95
bah faut remonter très très loin pour
trouver des grèves qui ont fait reculer
un gouvernement auriez eu des grèves
massives des manifestations massives
sous sarkozy
même si hollande est plus là ça c'est
violent parce que les gens n'y croient
plus tout simplement ce qui ne veut pas
dire je finirai par la queue dans les
sondages papa de sympathisants de droite
etc
mais dans les sondages est quand même et
même parmi eux d'ailleurs un sentiment
d'injustice sociale par rapport à la
politique menée par emmanuel macron qui
est quand même assez
ce sentiment est assez criant quand même
dans les rangs l'étude alors de
précisions donc les chiffres 50000
manifestants à paris selon la cgt 21500
selon le cabinet d'études occurrence et
11500 selon la pression je pense qu'on
dit la même chose 60 différentes quand
on demande aux gens est ce que macro est
juste ou injuste utilise la justesse
qu'il est proche ou d'histoire xixe
distant empathie ou pas de l'empathie
pas dans l'empathie évidemment quand on
leur demande est ce que la réforme acf
c'est bien ou pas bien
est ce que la réforme du rôle trail
c'est bien ou pas bien est-ce que la
réforme des retraites grosso modo ils
sont pas tous d'accord mais il ya plus
et même isf même la suppression de l'sf
je crois que c'est moitié moitié
mais oui à l'époque en tout cas quand on
le fait est là donc la construction du
discours quand elle s'applique à
maquereau devient très négative mais
mesure par mesure
c'est ce que je voulais dire c'est que
la politique in abstracto n'est pas
massivement rejeté c'est la façon dont
on la met en oeuvre
et celui qui la met en oeuvre début du
monde à des manuels macron en intime je
ne sais pas combien une fois que les
français sont dans une position
d'attenté
on attend on lui donne sa chance on va
laisser faire
bon peut-être ça bien marché pendant la
première année du quinquennat là on est
dans une zone un peu difficile mais je
pense aux le font les français ont
toujours envie lui donner raison de lui
donner sa chance pour réformer le pays
parce que d'une certaine manière oui je
pense même si vous croyez que c'est pas
vrai mais
les gens avec qui je parle il est bon il
y avait personne d'autre qui en avoir en
confiance pour redresser le pays il a
quand même fait un bon boulot on veut
aller en cours dans les sections mais
bon le ton presque qu'on aimerait bien
voir les résultats et c'est ça l'enjeu
de ce remaniement dont on parle dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure et pour emmanuel
macron et leur quand même ça de son côté
l deuxième chose c'est que les syndicats
sont quand même affaiblie
jeudi je suis d'accord avec madame que
les syndicats cherchent toujours à
quelque chose mais les syndiqués en
france sont très peu nombreux et
beaucoup de gens qui disent prêts à
faire grève autrefois maintenant il ne
veut plus faire grève parce qu'ils vont
perdre d'argent
on perd des journées de travail il peut
pas laisser leur entreprise pour les
faits graves
donc ils le font plus et c'est ça c'est
un changement dans la société française
maintenant que c'est d'histoire de
grandes gueules des 95 autres ne feront
plus récente parce que les gens ne veut
plus faire grève parce que d'un côté ils
n'ont pas les moyens de le faire et
deuxièmement je pense qu'ils croient
qu'avec syndicats n'ont plus le pouvoir
de faire bouger le gouvernement
et est ce que il n'ya pas une question
est-ce que d'autres questions non pas
supplanter les questions sociales
aujourd'hui les questions par exemple
d'identité d'immigration d'insécurité
culturel a été tellement vrai sur
l'élection présidentielle française
parce que justement par rapport à
d'autres pays il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
de pays en europe où les élections se
font sur l'immigration pour l'essentiel
les questions identitaires au sens plus
large celui du groupe devraient donner
votre message ou très fortement je vais
écrire dans vos colonnes donc le veut je
ne fais pas contredire mais malgré tout
par rapport à d'autres élections dans
d'autres pays européens
c'est moins vrai pour probablement aussi
parce que par rapport à d'autres pays de
toute une série de réformes du notamment
du code du travail qui était demandé par
l'europe et qui était d'une beauté est
demandée par la raison je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas été demandée en tout
cas par l'europe
ces réformes n'avaient toujours pas eu
lieu on est en retard en quelque sorte
par rapport à d'autres pays européens
désormais que ces réformes sont faites
pas entièrement peut-être pas la manière
dont tout le monde le souhaite et c'est
on aura forcément un retour vers les
questions identitaires vers lesquels
port régaliennes
mieux ça va mieux l'économie va moins
anciens intéresse pour s'intéresser à
d'autres motifs de mécontentement qui
sont l'identité l'immigration la
sécurité la sécurité culturelle aux
censeurs est-ce que par dong la
tricherie blain est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
autre phénomène qui joue également c'est
que autrefois c'étaient les classes
populaires qui était qui allait vers les
syndicats mais est ce que justement
n'est pas nouveau phénomène aujourd'hui
c'est le déplacement même des classes
moyennes qui est le sentiment dominant
est peut-être qu'elle s'exprime pas avec
les syndicats alors je ne vois pas
s'exprimer avec les syndicats du tout
parce que dans des classes moyennes mais
ça le concept de classe moyenne était
tellement organisation ils viendront non
mais c'est vrai vénérable où ça commence
et où ça se termine c'est vraiment très
très très difficile en revanche ce qu'on
appelait on va dire la classe moyenne
qui est juste voilà au dessus on va dire
du salaire médian c'est-à-dire qu'ils
gagnent entre 1700 et et 2002 ou 2003
celle là elle est inquiète parce que
celle là elle se sont déclassés et
surtout elle pense que ses enfants vont
être plus déclassé
et que et qu' ils sont donc dans une
situation d'impasse et d'inquiétude
profonde là et mais c'est pas ça qui va
les emmener vers les syndicats essaient
même pas forcément ça qui va les faire
manifester ou y qui va leur faire faire
une rentrée sociale
ils vont peut-être pu aller voter en dix
ans toute façon c'est plus la peine
s'ils sont vraiment très en colère ou
qu'ils ont eu un problème de sécurité
dans le quartier bas peut-être qu'ils
vont basculer sur de l'extrême droite ou
où le discours anti immigrés va jouer ou
le discours de l'invasion bon et là ils
basculeront aller sans droite à mon avis
ils basculeront absolument pas du côté
de l'extrême gauche
ils n'iront pas du côté de la france
atomise ils n'iront pas du côté du pc
j'ai donc dû peut-être si la france
soumise optait ou avait opté pour un peu
à la manière manière de deux de ces
partis allemands pour une fois une
espèce de boule d'anti quand ils besoin
d'anti libéralisme radical d'extrême
gauche
héééé ensuite pour la protection des
frontières contre les immigrés là on
aurait un cocktail qui seraient
potentiellement me semble t'il détonnant
et de succès pour mélenchon qui ne veut
qu'ils dont on sent parfois ils tournent
autour de cette possibilité mais qui ne
veut pas pour des raisons d'être pro
derrière ce discours
cette position en allemagne va donner on
ne le sait pas encore ça a surpris
absolument tu montes die linke est la
compagne de la fontaine qui fait ses
déclarations
ça fait un opéra de la bam un tabac
médiatique mais est ce que ça donnera
des résultats électoraux
on n'en sait strictement rien et de la
même façon
mélenchon avec sa position avec son
discours quand même internationaliste
très gauche même si à l'intérieur de son
parti on voit bien qu'il ya des tensions
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il y a quelques
uns qui disent oui mais il faut
comprendre la sécurité les frontières
autres il ne sera pas crédible lui en
tant que leader mélenchon deux points de
vue ne peut pas être crédible sur le
discours de la fermeture des frontières
du rejet de l'immigré il se met en
porte-à-faux
qu'est ce qu'elle ait l'électorat de
mélenchon cette année
tu auras non pas populaire de petits
fonctionnaires et pas seulement petits
fonctionnaires c'est un électorat
d'intellectuels bah écoutez mais non là
je suis catégorique parce que là il ya
toutes les données post électorale
montre que le lectorat de mélenchon est
un électorat qui est assez autant
électorat de macron est assez élitiste
et c'était au temps électoral mais
mélenchon est pas si populaire que ça
mais il est assez interclassiste en
réalité et lors il ya effectivement un
niveau de diplôme qui est un peu plus
élevé par rapport aux frais le
patrimoine culturel est plus élevée que
le patrimoine économique mais il ya
beaucoup aussi deux catégories
populaires c'est pour çà dire qu'il est
arrivé à 19%
ce n'est plus le lectorat simple rien à
voir avec l'électorat du npa par exemple
mais même à 19% ce jeudi il casserait
tellement son image s'il se mettait à
tenir un discours comme ça toi c'est
quoi enfin bref ça sent qu'il ne le fera
pas ne le fera pas même si la tentation
et là parfois de le faire dernier mot
filter là pour la simple raison que
s'ils commencent à parler des frontières
des immigrés l' immigration
si marine le pen qui volaient est tombé
dessus ont dit non mais voilà c'est lui
qui m'a contre elle depuis longtemps et
va maintenant il fait la même chose qu'à
salt lake et décrédibilise complètement
européen on l'a déjà vu sur le thème
europe
il a il a quand même changé de position
notamment vis-à-vis de l'europe on l'a
on est devenus fédéralisme ultra en
replaçant son d'iris comme il l'avait
été il a pas absolue il n'a pas changé
logiciel pour toutes ces raisons que
vous dites qui met mais malgré tout on
sent que de temps en temps il se dit que
là il ya quelque chose et moi je crois
que s'il abordait cette semaine berlin
où divers oui en tout cas on l'a entendu
justement un petit peu mettre de l'eau
dans son vin sur c'est sur ces questions
là notamment dans un discours à
marseille récemment qu'on a qu'on a à
jouer et je vous invite à revenir donc
dans les extraits de points de vue ou
qu'on a fait avec notamment de georges
et kossmann reach qui était l'un des
artisans de
de cette volonté de faire évoluer le
discours de la france est soumise
apparemment c'est nawak le discours de
marseille il ya quelques années oui il
avait dit vous de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée venait venait c'était enfin
bon et c'est même moment au même endroit
donc c'est assez frappant on va passer à
une autre
un autre thème il nous reste un petit
peu de temps pour se peut pour parler un
peu de littérature
après avoir cité quand même nos
internautes
guillaume qui nous dit ce qui est
dommage réside dans le fait que nos
syndicats français sont politisés
quelles sont les alternatives au
syndicat se demande arnaud usa et en
climat que nous dit attention ce n'est
pas parce que les français ne
manifestent pas qu'ils ne sont pas
mécontents alors c'est ce qu'on s'est
dit et macabre nitot nous précise le
nombre de travailleurs syndiqués ces 10%
constat qui parle de lui même
on va retourner à l'elysée mais dans le
passé
c'est un récit d'ailleurs à retrouver
dans le figaro daté d'aujourd'hui dans
l'édition papier à retrouver sur
lefigaro.fr signé etienne de montety le
29 et 30 les 29 et 30 octobre prochains
un millier de livres va être vendu aux
enchères alors particularités sont des
éditions originales anciennes ou et
luxueusement reliés et surtout elles ont
appartenu à un seul et même homme
françois mitterrand clip turn il ya un
livre que vous aimeriez acheter dans la
bibliothèque s'est fait chier à ce que
j'aimerais acheter
je pense que je prendrai madame bovary
de gustave flaubert tous alémaniques
c'est assez drôle parce que quand on
parle de littérature française
britanique bon on connaît pas grand
chose mais ça c'est un livre comme avec
les libdems isole par exemple qui qui
marche très bien où tu manges molière ou
d'élite du xviie siècle des pièces mais
c'est un livre que je trouve qu'il faut
à mon l'un des lits qui m'a le plus
marqué y'a flaubert dont je ne sais pas
s'il y en a pas voilà loin et flaubert
mais bon aussi il y parle et c'est ça
qui est frappant c'est que ya pas de sot
il ya peu de zola il dit il
quand il était patron l'unité 2 et zola
est très au dessus de tout et notamment
de barrès et attoub ares cadavres et il
ya je crois un vague zola ses traits à
face les chansons comme absolument
passionnant et la savage pour cela je
dois dire une chose parce qu'il ya une
chose que je prendrais si je pouvais
mais je pense que je ne vais pas pu voir
ses bureaux de françois mitterrand parce
que le bureau qui est moi sans aucun
intérêt d'ailleurs c'est un bureau on
disait oui il avait un grand bureau en
bois sculpté style louis 15 et en fait
non pas du tout mais c'est là l'un des
premiers images que j'ai eue de françois
mitterrand quand j'étais étudiant en
politique font saison comporte agne
c'était qu'il y avait deux images de lui
avait l'image de monarques de mitterrand
qui était là la grande nation de louis
xiv mais en même temps c'est un nombre
très simple qui aimait les choses
simples dans la vie il y avait une photo
très célèbre de lui assis à son bureau
avant qu'il soit élu président la
république mais sans rien autour et on
le voit ensuite en animalerie autre
exemple plus haut c'est quand même bien
réagir à la qualif est sculpté je crois
c'est en train de lire un livre
alexis mitterrand avait beaucoup de
romans etienne nous dit
il aimait plus le style que les
convictions ça vous rappelle quelque
chose s il ne cédait que roman ya pas d
ouvrages de sociologie que tout serait
content de l'économie de soi qu'on
dirait que c'est bas denses qui l'a
gardé il en a déjà fait dont il a fait
don des deux tiers ou des trois quarts
avant sa mort à la biotech de château
chinon et puis on a gardé ses livres les
beaux livres
les livres qu'ils avaient amoureusement
à acheter effet relier souvent par sa
femme d'ailleurs ou par des grands rôles
hier ça c'était ses livres et cela dès
hagaï elad en cela il ya ni histoire ni
l'économie ni sociologie nitoo ça il ya
du roman du roman du roman et c'est que
souvenir c'est vraiment une technique de
droite et souvent d'extrême droite
et quand on se dit qu'il a fait relié à
danielle mitterrand délimitant dont on
connaît les opinions il y faisait relier
brasillach comme le temps passe roman
pas mauvais un peu démodé les deux
étendards rebatet grands romans dont
dont françois mitterrand disait il ya
deux sortes d'hommes il ya ceux qui ont
lu les deux étendards de rejeter ceux
qui n'ont pas lu rauba tu es condamné à
mort qui doit s'exiler en espagne qu'il
est revenu enfin bon tout ça c'est des
écrivains collaborationniste diack
fusillé drieu on daniel relie drieu la
rochelle
donc c'est absolument inouïe d'imaginer
cette militante de gauche vendu le
travail génial mitterrand à qui fit
relier tous les auteurs d'extrême droite
c'est quelque chose de ce mot jacques
chardonne de gens donnent bien sûr et
puis tous les hussards et il s'amuse ans
il ya enfin ce qui m'étonne
il n'y a quasiment pas de balzac ce qui
hypothèque de droite edouard balladur
qui a pas balzac quasiment pas de troost
il ya une lettre à robert de montesquiou
de proust après un duel mais il n'y a
pas il ya juste une édition de donna
moore de swan et pascal non plus où un
seul donc il ya des c c'est quand même
beaucoup de l'entre-deux-guerres et
l'après guerre c'est aussi la biotech à
mon avis d'un ambitieux c'est le roman
la caractère et à dia pas
ils ont perdu les charentais qui me
regardent et surtout son conseil c'est
impossible à nos clients balzac
il ya une dimension sociologique photo
co qui était vraiment remarquable si
quand même pour décrire la société ou
19e et même se passant la révolution
industrielle
c'est extraordinaire balzac inquiète
c'est tout cette dimension-là qui
peut-être devait l'ennuyer un petit peu
mais je poursuive en jeu suivant le fil
je crois que c'est le roman par rapport
à la poésie le roman c'est toujours tout
cas le roman la française face à des
normands qui lie ces c'est d'abord
l'histoire généralement d'un individu
presque toujours d'un homme qui souvent
d'un jeune homme qui mène son chemin
c'est ça c'est donc c'est le l'égotisme
c'est effectivement cesser cela et ça
correspond tellement à ce qui a été
françois mitterrand des poèmes aussi
inédit de me philippe henriot fils de
boisbriand radio paris de la milice tués
par les résistants poèmes inédits jamais
publié il a achète le manuscrit qui se
fait très frappant aussi c'est que en
bonnet gothique menant bissieux c'est
également des romans d'initiation des
romans de parcours individuels qui
décline date de la sa jeunesse c'est ce
qui nous donnait aussi le courage ce qui
est très frappant lorsque je lui
aujourd'hui essentiellement dans les
pages du figaro aujourd'hui est bien
dans les romans que j'ai que j'ai aperçu
et bien c'est des romans qui ont été
écrits je ne dirais pas avant 3 pts 9 on
va dire plus tôt avant 45 victoires des
deux écrivains de la collaboration mais
a pris 45
y a plus grand monde je ne sais même pas
s'il y avait un grave par exemple ceux
ci n'ont après non en règle générale
quand même les années 50 où il ya les
cours d'eau plombier d'accord
qu'ils vérifient dédicaces très
personnelle y avait 50 jours même s'il
bouge même qu'il est écrivain dont il a
gagné à reus a rien laurent viadeo et
didier yah compagnie non ce qui est
amusant si un cas aucun dégât qui
l'entouré tout en y a pas franche
réussite bastide ya pas match galop y'a
pas tous ses écrits pour lg crise à
chalon il a beaucoup ça quand il fait
dès dimanche ses dix cas d'espèce je
l'avais payé marguerite duras payé par
great dur à lui qu'est ce que vous
pensez que c'est des diversifications
d'autres présidents lisez pas du tout
alors voilà c'est ça qui est qui et
comment on comptera chasse
on rappelle d'ailleurs que c'est par une
fiction sur le départ du président de la
république que démarre dès le livre que
vous avez dirigé avec semaine de royal
etc si le deuil du pouvoir puis c'est
l'occasion pour nous d'avoir un souvenir
une pensée une prière même pour paul
henri du limbert qui était directeur
délégué des rédactions du figaro et qui
nous a quittés il ya près d'un an et qui
a signé plusieurs fictions politiques
mais cette fois ci autour de françois
hollande au nom de le nom sous le nom d'
philippulus au long de sava et le coup
du père francois il ya dans les livres
de françois mitterrand un exemplaire des
comptes aux rimes de paul jean toulet
dans lequel ce poème en arles où sont
les alican prend garde à la douceur des
choses qui était un des poèmes favori de
paul henri voilà alors pour autographes
puisque pour tous l'air ajoutés à la
main ce problème là dedans
dans l'ouvragé kaka l'habitant de ses
contributions aux gens des pyrénées pour
l'heure on attend le dernier coup du
père maquereau et le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe et ce sera à suivre
on sait pas quand en direct mais ce sera
en direct sur figaro live
[Musique]